hi my name is Magnus I work for the
Google Drive team we're going to look at
the Google Drive integration for the
asus padfone device which allows you to
search in google drive and it also
incorporates the real-time API let's
have a look
oh no my google Drive API hottie on GG
malfunction sochi now Talon Tyson google
changshan size change I we are you
daughter in density out that she won't
she'll has enjoyed the search situated
richer how you make a comment now so wyd
hihi tacoma left a folder upload the
government such as the concision in the
corner then she poses make a cow service
though you know the fool now cool thai
food i had chicken gregorio 10 api now
take tournament I so Chico has some
woman came along with the short out
tolerance on so a year now Dogan
gokhan pinche target down i'll take
whatever do like em she said happy
Jewish and sleep under house storage
service final be Josh can see the cows
cow eat equations to this system before
i give you the reason why we choose
google drive to co-op or is let me share
with you our criteria of choosing
component and partners from a product
manager point of view there are three
criteria number one is quality for every
component that goes into the device it
should be of high and premium quality no
matter it's the cpu the chipset the
software the firmware or or the service
this should all be of high quality so we
choose google drive for its most
important quality most important trait
is the quality the second part is easy
of use it is very important for us to
think and to act like a user the
integration of gmail calendar picasa and
all other google services really give
user a true benefit and its really user
friendly so we choose google drive for
the second reason user friendly now
comes to the third part when we make any
device we want to have innovation in
aces we always think about what other
better way to finish the daily task of
ordinary people
how a device can help people so pet
phone together with Google Drive then
you can have a very easy way of
finishing almost ninety nine percent of
what you do on the web or on the go